[Music]
good morning
okay good
i was just checking whether you are
asleep or not
so thank you very much for attending my
talk i was a little bit worried
saying oh i'm gonna start the day two
at the gs conf
with the talk about mental health
knowing that it was a party yesterday
so it's it's hard to figure it out it's
going to be empty or not and just 10
minutes ago the room was empty
so
i'm antonia covo i'm principal
consultant at cantino in the uk
and i want to clarify a couple of things
i'm not a pandemic expert and i'm not a
mental health expert
okay
and
about the communication thing i want you
to tell me after the talk
if
what i've been told is true i have some
colleagues in the uk on a previous job
that they were from hungary and they
told me you know
you only need four awards
in hungarian to live here ten days so
you can tell me after if egan
kosonom gratulock and palinca
are enough
so just on the q a please let me know
whether i have to thank them or not
so i'm
going to talk a little bit about my
family
because it's important talking about
mental health about the family well i'm
from spain
so that's the reason i have a weird
accent
and oh
in 2005 i moved to paris and i have to
learn french from there
because astonishingly they don't speak
spanish there
and
maybe it was one of the reasons that i
moved out in 2014 but to a wrong country
there's still no spanish there
but i'm there now and i'm even british
now
i met there my wife that she's from
slovakia
cool
and we have a beautiful daughter that
luckily for her she looks like my wife
and nothing
so the rest of my family i'm not going
to
tell you anything about the husbands or
wives of my siblings and you will
understand soon why
my mother lives in toledo in spain
and i have two sisters there on the same
city
i also have another sister living in
zaragoza also in spain
most of the people with four siblings
it's okay right
but i have one brother living in granada
also in spain
and
another one and another one one in
sevilla
and
sister in paris so you can imagine
six different cities three different
countries
it's really weird for us to be all
together
in fact i remember once talking on
on the family group
that you know the last time we were all
together it was in 2013 when my father
died
and we say we need to change that let's
let's try to be together on a happy
moment and not on a sad one
and we found
the idea moment the 75th birthday of my
mother
we were going to be all together there i
was going to travel from uk
10 days in spain
my mother was so excited buying a lot of
nice food and so on
nice plan right
i forgot to tell you one thing important
the 75th birthday of my mother was 19th
march 2020.
so
it wasn't as we planned
it was like that
that was my mother's version
and i don't know if you've ever been to
spain
a lot of blogs flats they're usually
like that with a swimming pool in the
middle and
the play area and there's
some some flats that actually you have
the wind out there and you can see the
swimming pool and everything it's great
you don't have the noise of the road
but in a pandemic
you see now one
there is no one on the swimming pool
you don't see even cars
you remember all the videos at the
beginning of the pandemic the guy with
the sock eating
cars like
my mother wasn't able to even do that
so she was two weeks without seeing
anyone
at all
and it was really hard especially the
first two weeks we remember at the time
we didn't know a lot about copying and
it was always
in two weeks you would know whether you
have it or not
and that's the scariest in those two
weeks
and she was alone
the good thing
is we have a
a strange sense of humor so at least we
were having a lot of video calls and she
was saying you know these two weeks
they're really hard but probably is the
two weeks of my life that i've eaten the
best food because i bought everything
for all of you there was i don't know
20 people coming to see her
and i have turkey a lot of browns and
everything so probably it's i never buy
this kind of things for myself because
i'm alone so
it was good and it's
so important to have a good sense of
humor and video calls all the time right
i think that it was amazing surviving
for all of us
it was we were able to do video calls
i'm really lucky or
happy that we decided some time ago to
buy an ipad to my mom so she could have
messengers and calling us
otherwise without that
it was happening harder right
i'm sharing this with you not only
because you're going to say oh poor
antonium for mom it's it's just one
story
but i realized after that
that all of us here we're privileged
we're privileged right now because we
are here
not a lot of people can say that we are
here right
and also realize that
with my work
i was having a good work before pandemic
during the pandemic i could keep my work
a lot of people was able to even change
jobs
and get a better job
others they lose it but it was a lot of
opportunities and now i feel privileged
and i can work for a company that say
you work where you work best in uk so if
you don't want to go to the office no
one is going to force you that only if
you want to go
that's a privilege
and every day that we open our eyes
this talk
is not about me sharing all my
experience and all the tips
it's about a lot of people that
willingly they share with me their
stories and the small tips
i have a lot of people from different
countries
a lot of immigrants living in uk like
myself
sharing a flat in uk i don't know if you
ever work
live in london
but there are some flats that you don't
even have a living room the living room
is a bedroom from someone else so you
are sitting in a flat and you only have
a kitchen and your room
and of course you're not going to talk
to the brother because you don't know
whether they have coffee or not
right
one of the privilege is to have a house
with a garden
i don't know who have a garden here i
have a small garden and that was
liberation
all the stories that i'm gonna share and
the small tips
you can think that it's a little bit to
keep saying your body your mind and your
soul
and of course
everything i'm going to share i haven't
followed
everything
i have to prioritize
you could feel the beating body miners
and soul
which one i didn't prioritize right
because i couldn't all the three at the
same time it was too hard
right
so another story that is not
for me well i live in uk end of 2020
we have our uk barian of kovit
and the uk wasn't a great place to be in
the world
so one of my colleagues
he wasn't from the uk
the school already announced the whole
year is going to be homeschooling
so what
he thought i'm gonna send my wife and my
two kids
with my family my home country because
here in uk it's not going well
and it's all right i think it's it's a
good plan right
you could do the same probably to try to
keep your family
safe especially when you don't know
what's happening
something happened of course
can anyone say what's that
delta
now i forgot to say
like my the birthday of my mom
he was from india
he sent end of 2020 his family to india
because india at that time was really
really good on all the statistics and
things like that
and he had
every night thinking
wow i've sent my two kids and my wife
there
he even lost two of his uncles there
while his family was there
so it was really hard for that person
after working hours to think
about his family
so what did he do
i think that he managed to get nearly
every possible certification on azure he
was studying all the time he was trying
to keep the mind completely busy so i
don't have to think about my family only
when they call me
and he was trying always to talk with
the colleagues myself and things like
that and it's keeping your mind busy
trying to learn every day something
it helped him help a lot of different
people and now
that is the different times with a
pandemic
it's something that we should keep
it's a little bit like
try to become a better person of
yourself every time
that's the reason i usually like to wear
this t-shirt because for me it's try to
level up every day
try to become better
other problems are space
in london
flats and houses are really really
expensive
that's expensive that i don't even live
in london i live really far from london
i know a lot of families they shared
with me that
they were renting really really small
flats or small houses because on
weekends they could go to any park a lot
of things because london has a lot of
offering and i assume that it's like in
every capital in every country the
capital has a lot of theaters a lot of
parks a lot of activities for kids so
it's not a problem if your house is
really small because you can live
outdoors
but then you have the homeschooling
being at home the kids all the time and
both parents needing to work from home
that changed our lives right
and then it's
you need to find a space in your house
and you don't know how
one of the
things that a lot of people told me
is with the shed on the garden
a lot of people started working on the
shed
the problem is
if you didn't have the shed already
ready it was impossible for two months
to get any material for the
diy because it was completely sold out
so a lot of them started to work on the
shed without anything just within a long
cable of the electricity or just working
two hours there then i go
i plug my laptop my wife can work two
hours there and i stay with the kids and
that was the way to actually have a
little space for themselves
and then
little by little they were improving the
shirts i've seen some says that people
show me that it's better than some flats
that i lived in paris
it's incredible
but i'm unable to do diy i'm
and i have two left hands for that
the key thing for them and for everyone
that you have the homeschooling is
everything that you are getting that you
didn't have before
so i remember when i was commuting
before
there was a lot of days
that when i left home
my daughter was sleeping and when i
arrived home
my daughter was sleeping
so from monday to thursday because
luckily i was able to work from home on
fridays i didn't see my daughter
only on videos on pictures
and now with all the situation
she's five years old now and i've been
with her since every day having lunch
having lunch with my wife
that
it's it's a good thing so it's those
small moments
that probably we didn't realize before
that
it's it's the sense of life for me now
is to enjoy those small moments
because they work it's going to be there
tomorrow
those are small moments we don't really
know if we are going to have them
tomorrow so just enjoy those small
moments
[Applause]
impostor syndrome
i can literally give a full talk about
imposter syndrome like some of you know
but i'm not going to do that
a lot of people that share stories with
me
they were all sharing a moment that is
one of the traits of impostor syndrome
that is comparing yourself with your
teammates
normally it's imposter syndrome you're
comparing the others
with you and your self-esteem is really
low that you always think that they are
really really great and you are the one
that is
just getting the team down
it was worse during the pandemic
because a lot of people have the feeling
that i don't understand i don't have
force
to smile on the webcams and i have some
of my teammates they're smiling all the
time they feel like they are enjoying
that their life is great and i don't
i cannot feel
a reason to to smile with everything
that is happening
you have to stop comparing yourself with
others
there is only one
comparison that it matters
it's not about
the people putting on instagram
and nice scenes or on social media
the real comparison that matters is how
you were yesterday and how you are today
you have to strive
micro improvements
if you feel like
you are like a three out of ten today
don't try to be
four out of ten tomorrow that might be
too hard but try to be
3.001 tomorrow and try to feel
how could i know
if tomorrow i'm gonna be
that
small better
once you figure it out how
then you can make it happen
and
don't try to aim to be a 10 out of 10.
you're on a three command you cannot be
a 10
and probably if you're already on a
seven on a
you're okay you don't need to be a 10.
perfection is the enemy of great we only
need to be great right
before pandemic did you have a fixed
desk in your office that it was your
allocated desk
hands
among all of you did you have anything
that it was a picture of your family a
little toy a little lego something that
it was different it was you
do you do the same on your workspace at
home or do you have just the laptop
because that's one of the key things
even if you were working from the
kitchen table at the beginning
a tip that a lot of people told me is
they were putting the picture of the
family or the little lego that they were
having on the office or a different lego
just
to find like it's my space working like
before
have something that is a personal story
so you see all the aloe veras there
i like to put them there so that's my
working space now it wasn't like that at
the beginning of the pandemic but it got
better
when i got them they were that tiny
and i got them in forte ventura on my
honeymoon
so when i'm feeling a little bit down i
can always look how they grow
i i can't think
i have grown as well
since 2016.
so
i have one lego that you cannot see in
the star wars over there
and also it's a little bit messy i know
but well
i cannot be perfect right
the thing is if you personalize your
desk
you feel like working sometimes it's not
working it's something that you feel
confident you feel comfortable
and that's a good thing right
morning exercise or exercise
i'm really good finding excuses to avoid
exercise
and
my surprise
was
alone no
a lot of people they were really good
finding excuses to avoid doing exercise
this one tip that it didn't work for me
because on fridays when i was working
from home before pandemic i was always
on sport clothes
so for my mind being on sport clothes it
didn't mean not to be working
but for some people
especially some that they were always
working in the office
they never dare to have spare clothes in
the office
so for them
if i'm export clothes
i'm gonna practice a sport so for the
brain it was working like that
the problem is
you can find excuses to avoid doing that
and more than one it was my surprise
found
really trick
if you have your mind already used that
when you are on the sport clothes you
are going to do exercise
how do you ensure that you don't find an
excuse like it's raining
because it's cold
because in uk it's raining i don't know
400 every year 400 days every year right
they
change
the first thing in the morning without
opening the curtains
or without even checking the weather
so i changed and then i opened
oh but like it's raining but
i'm gonna do it anyway the exercise
because i have the spark loads
and i found that genius when you have
that mentality that is whatever you are
wearing
i'm doing it and it was probably the
same people that for them they were
always
getting dressed to work instead of a
normal t-sword the things like that it
was
with dessert and things like that
because it was helping them i was like
wow that's really cool
but it doesn't work for me but i know
that it was working for others and maybe
it will work for some of you
the work-life balance and the
time for yourself
one of the things that i was
missing
the first months of the pandemic
i have a long commuting to go to london
it's one hour train
is 20 minutes walk one hour trend and
between 10 and 20 minutes walk
i didn't like the commuting itself but
it was really important for me because i
was able to switch
between working mode and home mode
now
what during the pandemic exchange didn't
have that time i was able to get calls
at 7 00 a.m and 7 p.m and so on
but now we are back to the office but
maybe you are back
one day a week
that's one thing that it works for me
and it works for a lot of people
i block
the commuting time whether i'm going to
the office or not
and also coming back
and the lunch
the time of this for you are not for
working you keep it
if one that you're going to the office
then you know what's
that's train walking and everything if
you are not
you can use that
to do your morning exercise the bike
to read a book
to do nothing at all but it's your time
and
normally if you tend to block your
calendar
people are nicer now and they don't put
meetings or at least you can actually
reject me this because sorry i'm missing
at that time
right they don't need to know what
you're doing
just put in private meeting
and that really works that help me
ensuring that i'm not working
seven till seven with a desktop
because that's important
and ensuring that i can have time for me
that my
mind can actually do the switch
for me right now it's really great but
my daughter five years old first year in
school i can bring her to school every
day
four days a week because one day i'm
going to london
but i'm lying even sometimes i do the
five days and i'm just going
late to the office because
why not right
it's in terms of priorities
go to the school with my daughter
working so for me it's pretty clear
and you should probably do the same
disconnects from work
the end of the working day
a lot of people share with me that what
they do when they want to finish work or
start work
they go out they open the door
go walk
to the block and come back sometimes
it's only five minutes but that's enough
for them
to let them the brain
i need more than five minutes probably
my brain is a little bit slow especially
in the mornings but that that helps a
lot for a lot of people
they also have to do the same when you
want to do regular breaks did you find
when you were working from home
especially at the beginning of the
pandemic that you were doing three or
four hours in a row without any break
because it was happening to me i wasn't
realizing and then i was
i'm really ecky oh fans too tired oh man
four hours
so now i'm always trying to do the same
breaks that i was doing in the office
in the office i only needed to see if
someone that i like is going to the
coffee machine and say oh time for a
break
and then you talk right
now i do the same but this i put an
alarm actually
on the clock on my oh coffee time and i
go to the first floor of coffee
and i start now that it's spring
see i have a garden
watch in the beds for five minutes
if you put the food
it happens quite often
and that helps all also to try to focus
your eyes on a distant point
because it's not good to be full time
without any break
just in front of the screen
so
i focus on the bird five or ten meters
and my eyes are actually resting while
i'm enjoying the birds fighting between
them
sometimes i have to run
because around
i don't know 80 of my neighbors they
have cats
and i just realized that even the traps
with the ultrasounds
they know now where are the ultrasounds
and that
the cats are really so in the morning
they're usually hiding i have to run
maybe that's my morning exercise well
ah
you can see clearly that's not one of
the advice that i do
even though i love salmon
the healthy food if you don't do
exercise and you don't do healthy food
you're gonna get some kilo
that i i have proven that so you don't
have to try
when you needed to go to the office
before for me it was really easy i
wasn't cooking i was just going out
one of those
ready meal
and eating i don't have to prepare food
oh you're working from home you need to
prepare food
but in one hour i cannot prepare
everything i said it's off i end up
eating sandwich all the
time and a lot of people that they were
actually cooking before they told me oh
i keep cooking on sundays for the whole
week i'm putting in the freezer and this
is in the morning i just put the food
exactly as i was doing before
that helped me to be relaxed on sunday
before
and to have
the time to enjoy food
and i find really really nice that
i'm not really good planning my
weekly food i'm
good planning
how others can work or how
others can improve your
but for me it's complicated always right
one of the good things even if you are
doing healthy food all the time
and that is what i did some years ago
some diet even the nutritionist say
you cannot be doing all the time the
boring food
so they allow me at that time once a
week to have a nice dessert or even
twice a week depending on the moment
because
it's a little reward that you're making
for yourself so it's the same if you do
the batch cooking but
before you were going on fridays to your
teammates to a nice food you can even
prepare that and have a nice food
every friday right
that's controversial for some people i
don't know why
make friends at work
so
it's one of the things sometimes it's
can be a little bit queer when we're in
front of the
computer all the time and we don't like
people to come to us
but for me i realize that
when i find someone that i can talk
about anything or we have affinities
i'm working better and i'm even more
willing to help the rest of the company
only because there's one or two that i i
feel better right
it's like craig was saying yesterday to
find a
a working wife or husband but
it sounds a little bit too extreme for
me but it's it's the same thing right
and it's
now when i go to the office
i don't do it really really for working
doing it because i want those personal
interactions
and that gives me the energy for the
rest of the week
so i have a choice to go or not to the
office and i decided because i can
see the people right
it's a lot of
small tips that probably you're already
done
doing a lot
if you have a new one i'm more than
happy if you share it with me
so i
put some together
for me
work by leg balance is the most
important for me from my context
because i don't know whether i have the
opportunity to do that on my personal
life tomorrow
and the work
is going to be always tomorrow on the
day after and so on it's a
you know if for any reason
you are not here tomorrow
in the work they will find someone to
replace you
in your personal life they won't find
someone to replace
just think about it
don't stop learning or to improve micro
improvements all the time
that keeps me sane and sometimes it's
good
yes i cannot learn anything new today
but i'm gonna try tomorrow that's at
least that feeling right
customize your workspace or
something that makes you yourself at
this the work is fun even when i'm
working from home
so
it might be anything and
it also gives a lot of conversations
when someone see on the webcam what's
that
those games are books and i said oh
that's graphic novel from marvel or dc
but i'm revealing that i'm a geek to
everyone but at least i'm talking about
someone else something else right
daily exercise
or exercise maybe daily is a little bit
optimistic
walking is also exercise if you don't do
it normally and it's easy to do
at least for me i can do that one
so try to do it
especially on that time of commuting
time that you have blocked on your
calendar because you are going to do
that now right
healthy food
and treating yourself from time to time
yeah we all like
pizza from time to time right but every
day is not good
regular breaks that's key i like before
when i was wearing one of the feed beads
before i
was using it i like it the when you can
put it that it's going to vibrate if you
haven't moved for one hour
that's the most amazing thing that i
have used in the past just to ensure
that i'm standing up and going out and
coming back
and make friends at work or even
on the train or something
one of the things that i do now
i have a friend that we we try to do
every two or three months and we say we
have salad time
are you saying salad time after
everything that you're talking about
healthy food
you are right
for those in london there is a chain of
sushi and chicken catsuit curry that we
love
and when we were talking before pandemic
let's have a salad it's a chicken katsu
curry because it has chicken vegetables
and rice and you can do salads with
those three right so that's my trick to
the
housing and
it's my friend so he's always doing that
and we're on different companies now and
i had a salad with him last week and it
was amazing
kosanan
[Applause]
you